Kip.
Hi Kip, sorry about that. I'm stuck in another meeting.
Hey, how are you doing?
Good. Ryan's out this week, so it was on my calendar. Sorry about that. I was just stuck in another meeting still.
Yeah, that's fine, that's fine. So, is he okay? I mean, he is doing okay.
He's just on vacation.
Okay, okay.
And he took a week off.
OK, alright.
So how are you doing?
Good, good, I'm good. Good, busy, but I'm good. Moving around A lot.
So.
And how are things going with the engineers, so we have it at the end?
They've been doing a wonderful job, they said, been keeping the...
They help me out a lot. They help out most of my team. I haven't heard any complaints. Nothing but good things from our side of things, as you know. So we're doing well.
St.
Okay, correct, correct.
With.
All right, so.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've already shared the presentation, so let me know if you are ready or you want me to email or how you want to move ahead.
Hoh.
I mean, honestly, they've been doing really well. So at this point, like, with Ryan being out this week, this may be one where you might want to wait till he's back for stuff to get some more accurate stuff. Not because I don't work with them as much, but they keep me out of operation stuff nowadays. They try to keep me separated as best they can.
But if we want, we probably just want to, if you want, you probably sent out an invite for next week around this time. He'll be back next week if you want to, so you can do this call then. Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, definitely. No problem. We can do this next week.
Just because that means you'll get you'll get better information if you're on the phone with him than you are with me. I can give you all I can give you is so that Amit C are doing a wonderful job. That's about all I can give you.
Absolutely.
Yeah, no problem. We can schedule this for next week and yeah, around same time should be okay. Same day, same time. Okay, okay, sounds good. Okay, I will send the invite and yeah, thank you for joining, Thomas. Yeah, yeah, bye-bye.
Mhm.
Yep.
Yeah.
All right, thank you, Kip.
Perfect. Have a good one, Kip. Bye.